bienvenue dans le débat politique ces
derniers temps emmanuel macron s'affiche
avec des personnalités hors système une
visite au professeur didier raoult est
un coup de téléphone à l'humoriste jean
marie bigard dont le secret n'a pas fait
long feu
elle cette politique spectacle certes
elle les intérêts du président ou pas
des acteurs et des humoristes qui font
de la politique
on l'a vu aussi cette semaine avec la
déclaration d'une star de télé crochet
largement relayée dans les médias est ce
qu on marche sur la tête c'est la
question que nous posons ce soir et pour
en débattre nous sommes avec georges
kiejman aux vice présidents de
républiques souveraines et nicolas
balises cofondateur de l la république
en marche
bonsoir à tous les deux merci d'être
avec nous sur rt france un candidat
antisystème pourrait-il émerger pour le
prochain scrutin présidentiel
la page facebook didier rahout président
de la république pour 2022 rassemble
déjà 24 mille membres le scientifique
qui est d'ailleurs assez populaire et il
le sait écoutez le c'était cette semaine
moi je suis une star des maladies
infectieuses
j'ai tenu j'ai un cursus qui fait rêver
à peu près n'importe qui aussi bien la
fonction officielle j'étais plus jeune
président d'université de france le
jeune brillant médecin
le premier le plus jeune de tous les
maires de tous les professeurs la classe
exceptionnelle le professeur le plus
ancien dans le grade le plus élevé de
tous pays en médecine j'ai tout eu dans
ma vie donc si vous laissez moi l'élite
et voilà c'est moi qui suis l'élite
georges kuzmanovic que pensez vous de la
déclaration de didier raoul certains
français pensent qu'il allait les
épaules pour faire de la politique
est ce qu'il incarne selon vous un
candidat potentiel un candidat
antisystème
je trouve qu'il a un ego qui est au
moins aussi impressionnant que celui
d'emmanuel macron un candidat
antisystème qui représenterait le peuple
devrait ne pas être du système déjà
parce que monsieur raout en est
largement il se définit lui-même comme
étant
de l'élite il est de l'élite c'est un
très grand virologues plutôt un
spécialiste en biologie médicale et et
que dire la politique c'est un peu plus
vaste que les problèmes médicaux qui
sont centraux que la santé qui est
également centrale mais il y en a
d'autres
et cette manière de faire tout à fait
bonapartiste je ne suis pas sûr que ça
marche longtemps avec par exemple des
gens comme parmi les sondés gilet jaune
qui qui qui souhaitent plus de
démocratie plus de souveraineté
populaire plus de retour de la
démocratie ou au peuple médiévale du
crédit et elle est gérée je vis d'un
décret c'est bien mais tant qu'il est
encore une fois tant qu'on est dans
l'opposition
tant qu'on est dans un critique sur un
point spécifique on a du crédit
mais une fois qu'on entre en action et
qu'on prend des décisions le crédit
peuvent s'en aller et les questions on
peut venir et c'est légitime le peuple
peut avoir envie de donner son d'avoir
son mot à dire
et si dans ce cas là on a un personnage
comme raul qui dit non mais vous savez
moi je suis dit et je sais le mieux
faire que tout le monde c'est pas sûr
que ça passe très très longtemps on a
déjà testé avec monsieur manuel marron
ça ne passe pas ça ne passe pas du tout
alors c'est quelqu'un est évidemment qui
s'opposent à la théorie du gouvernement
notamment sur les drogues si chloroquine
d'où sa popularité d'ailleurs comment
vous expliquer nicolas bailly ce le fait
qu' on en face même un gourou et que les
français adhèrent à ce personnage est ce
que c'est aussi les médias qui l'ont
fabriqué selon vous c'est fabriqué lui
même je pense et je partage pour une
fois c'est rare une partie de la vie de
georges coste malovic sur la
personnalité du professeur raoult et
elles sont décodés mesuré que je ne
comparerai pas au président de la
république dans des périodes de crise
les gens ont toujours besoin
c'est traditionnel de se rattacher à des
symboles de se rattacher à des personnes
souvent dans l'opposition et la somme
des mécontentements ne fait pas un
programme politique et monsieur 88 l'a
rappelé c'est pas parce que vous amener
des gens derrière vous parce qu'ils sont
mécontents que vous avez un programme
politique alors proposé alors en tout
cas ça montre qu'il n'ya pas non plus de
personnalité politique qui fasse
l'unanimité aujourd'hui puisqu'on se
tourner vers des personnes de la société
civile la dernière en date c'est jean
marie bigard on lui a demandé s'il
allait se présenter à la présidentielle
écoutez sa réponse
ça pourrait m'intéresser si je sentais
l'utilité d'avoir quelqu'un de sincère
qui représente réellement le peuple est
là on voit là georges kiejman au vite
une autre personnalité publique cet
humoriste jean marie bigard qui aussi
fait de la politique il en il en fait
déjà d'ailleurs mais qui a reçu un coup
de téléphone du président de la
république d'où ma question
emmanuel macron va aussi côtoyé ces
personnalités là pour quelles raisons
selon vous monsieur nicolas maïs elle
apprendra sûrement mieux puisqu'il
connaît mieux monsieur emmanuel macron
mais je crois qu emmanuel macron un
léger défaut c'est qu'il est et c'est
pour ça que je parlais dgo il est
absolument convaincu de la capacité de
son verbe à convaincre n'importe qui
même ses opposants
de nombreux témoins évoquent cela et
c'est pour cela qu'il s'expose je pense
il s'est exposé sans réfléchir
vraiment clairement à ce qui allait
s'ensuivre a appelé monsieur bigard ou
appeler monsieur ou aller voir monsieur
rares août
je pense pour tenter de convaincre sans
succès parce que ce sont des gens qui
ont fait des positions c'est vrai si
vous pensez pas c'est pour dire aux
français voyez ces gens là aussi je les
côtoie et c'est pour les banaliser en
quelque sorte vous pensez pas je pense
qu'il essaie de les convaincre et 2 et 2
et de les calmer et de davy telle
attaque alors que je pense que ça
s'amplifie
qu'en pensez-vous micola ba isse
pourquoi emmanuel macron m
on le sait se frotter aux personnes qui
sont assez atypique voire populiste je
côtoie emmanuel macron il ya une part de
sa personnalité que j'apprécie
énormément c'est de vouloir sentir en
permanence les choses les gens le pays
un pays dont il n'est pas coupé quoi que
certains essayent essaye de dire et
c'est c'est pour sentir ce pays c'est
pour sentir ces courants d'idées que
qu'emmanuel macron appelle ces
personnalités ça en aucun cas ni pour
les convaincre je pense ni pour essayer
de les neutraliser
mais quand vous voyez des des vidéos de
jean marie bigard relayer des millions
de fois pendant la période de
confinement notamment sur les caps et
notamment sur ce genre de questions
elles sont vu des millions de fois elle
parle de quelque chose
elles ont une touche le l'opinion donc
elle symbolise quelque chose en pays à
un instant t et le président d akoupé du
pays donc le président se rapproche de
ces gens là pour entendre pour entendre
ce qu'ils ont à dire
wells aboliront des ces pressions une
déception peut-être c'est ce qu'elle
symbolise nicolet maïs mais vous savez
une candidature une candidature type
jean marie bigard outil peu professeur
raoul ce sera pas emmanuel macron que
cela nuira saluera aux candidats qui
cherchent traditionnellement à se
présenter comme les contes les candidat
antisystème
on voit bien il ya un sondage qui a été
fait sur l'éventualité d'une candidature
de jean marie bigard remet ça prend des
voix au rassemblement national et ça
prend des voix à la france a soumises
ça en prend très peu dans l'électorat de
ce qu'on appellera
l'électorat traditionnel de gauche de
centre ou de droite
réaction georges kuzmanovic pourquoi est
ce que les français certains français se
tournent vers ce genre de personnalité
selon vous mais parce que le personnel
politique classique de gouvernement et
ils en ont ras-le-bol et un raison on a
quand même plusieurs gouvernements
plusieurs présidences où se succèdent
des gens qui se disaient de gauche ou
qui se disait de droite et qui applique
les mêmes politiques néolibérales
invariablement et transferts année après
année
un peu de plus de souveraineté de la
france vous auriez monsieur nicolas
bailly se mais monsieur macron parle
souveraineté européenne et qu'il faut
faire une transfert de souveraineté de
la france et donc la spré ans je vous
invite à lire le lycée mais qui ne
traitaient d'aix-la-chapelle il assez
clair en termes de transferts de
souveraineté y compris sur les sur la
somme était la plus importante celle du
feu nucléaire et d'indépendance
nationale militaire excusez moi le
problème c'est que ce sont des
différents gouvernements qu'incarne
monsieur le mans à maquereau qui casse
les services public qui font que le
travail est moins bien payés et les
riches sont plus riches à un moment
donné et surtout pour ceux qui ont
promis qu'il y aura plus de justice
sociale le peuple en a marre et le
peuple ne fait plus confiance à ces la
sas et j'en ai donc je dis mais pourquoi
pas un autre candidat
ceux là ont failli ont failli ont failli
depuis 30 ans ça va de mal en pis
pourquoi pas un autre
et puis ya des exemples européens bon
c'est vraiment pas du tout la même chose
en france je pense en l'occurrence ap
pellegrino avec le mouvement 5 étoiles
qui la voudrait plus organisés qu'il a
fondée mais on va en parler je voudrais
que nicolas bays réagi si vous vouliez
répondre nicolas bailly
c'est vraiment ce qui nous différencie
avec georges moi je crois à l'europe
et je crois que cette europe est là pour
nous protéger alors l'europe actuelle il
faut changer
grand partisan fonctionnement il faut
certainement que les peuples d'europe
puissent intervenir beaucoup plus sur
les choix faits au niveau européen mais
cette europe gilles paquin nous
permettra de peser face au géant chinois
demain par exemple on va on va revenir
sur quand il ya un référendum populaire
que ce soit en europe et spécifiquement
en france en 2005 le peuple dit non non
pas l'europe n'ont pas ou partenariat
européen bien évidemment mais il dit non
à cette europe là cette europe
néolibérale qui nuit aux intérêts des
citoyens comme autant de peuples dans
autant de pays européens votre contre
systématiquement on ne peut pas
continuer à dire mais si on peut faire
une belle robe de l'intérieur alors que
les traités sont des traités néolibéraux
qui garantissent les intérêts
principalement des banques des
institutions financières et des plus
riches dans cette hausse 1,7 union
européenne et pas des peuples
georges kiejman oui je vous parlais de
beppe grillo qui effectivement a fondé
le mouvement 5 étoiles qui est
aujourd'hui au pouvoir en italie il y a
eu aussi donald trump aux états unis ou
à flot d'émigrés winski en ukraine que
l'on voit ici à l'écran vous pensez que
l'émergence de ce type de personnage ne
peut pas se faire en france est-ce que
c'était dès le début de votre idée bon
comparé pp grillo donald trump
pas vraiment c'est pas vraiment le même
type de personnage ni de capacités non
j'ai pas dis que ce n'est pas possible
en france
j'ai dit que derrière donald trump et
une puissance financière colossale il
est milliardaire il a toute une série de
réseaux et puis c'est un personnage
médiatique très connu aux états unis qui
dans les médias à des réseaux qui lui
assure une certaine puissance et il peut
lever des fonds bric est extrêmement
important dans la politique aux états
unis en italie pp grillo n'était pas
juste un bigard qui donnait son avis
était été
ok maurice le précise bien sûr mais il
était là la partie émergée d'un iceberg
beaucoup plus puissant avec un parti
organisé comme une entreprise avec des
fonds et des gens derrière lui ce qui
n'est pas du tout le cas de deux pour le
moment de quelqu'un comme comme monsieur
bigard et et vladimir weiss qui en
ukraine n'avait pas forcément il avait
sa notoriété pour lui oui mais bon
l'ukraine et a failli qui est dans un
chaos économique politique et morale
total où tous ceux qui promettaient que
il arrêterait la corruption des autres
ultras corrompu avant ont failli à la
fin donc ces prix je vous dis le peuple
en a marre tout la résine et pourquoi
pas la raison pourquoi pas pourquoi
pourquoi pas un humoriste rigolant
activement contre s'il garde son sens de
l'humour nicolas maïs quand on sait où
est ce qu'un ce type de personnage anti
système pourrait émerger en france on
atteint là où j'arrête on sait que les
trois exemples que vous n'avez vous pas
comparable aujourd'hui avec l'émergence
d'une personnalité puisque ce sont trois
personnes qui sont encore un atelier sur
des partis politiques structurées donald
trump avait les républicains il était
tranquille à des républicains la plus
grande famille avec des mots politique
avec les démocrates aux états unis et
des griots est arrivé au pouvoir avec un
qui était déjà structuré qui fait
d'ailleurs très vite des structures et
parce que c'est parfois aussi le risque
de ces personnalités quand elle est au
pouvoir
elle arrive en carton sur les
mécontentements en surfant sur une vague
mais sans créer un programme capacité
politique derrière et le souffle et se
dégonflent en france vous avez vous
alors si demain on est un proche je
pense vous entendez vous entend mal
nicolas bailly
on va on va essayer de 2,2 de procéder à
quelques réglages je voudrais qu'on
écoute coluche qui lui aussi
souvenez-vous s'était présenté à
l'élection présidentielle et à l'époque
en 1981 il avait obtenu 15% d'intentions
de vote c'est pas rien écouté le
[Applaudissements]
et voilà pour coluche en 1981 georges
kiejman oui je vois sourire
est ce que ce sont les médias finalement
qui donne trop de crédit à ce type de
candidature
non pas du tout je pense que ces
candidatures qui représente quelque
chose de légitime et ici en son temps
c'était très différent encore une fois
coluche agrégé 15% de soutien de la part
de nos concitoyens ou que d'autres voter
pour des humoristes ailleurs c'est que à
un moment donné sérieusement les
citoyens concert que le système ne va
pas dans le sens ne va pas dans le sens
de l'intérêt général
il se dit c'est une vaste rigolade
pourquoi ne pas pourquoi ne pas mettre
un bouffon pourrait casser pour casser
la machine
ça me semble parfaitement parfaitement
logique c'est pas tant les médias qui
font qu'ils font cela en fait qui relaie
en tout cas qui relèvent
oui mais c'est les médias relaient aussi
des candidats comme monsieur emmanuel
macron qui était assez peu connu qui a
fait des centaines de couvertures qui
était largement appuyée par ses amis
dans les médias gens pensent at his
group
monsieur travail ou enfin ça il est
aussi aidée par par ce genre de choses
un candidat moins connus qui n'a pas
accès aux médias qui n'a pas serré zola
ou qui n'a pas la notoriété humoristique
ou d'un acteur ben il évidemment qu'il
va galérer beaucoup plus pour accéder
aux médias mais le talent d'un coluche
n'est pas le fait seulement du des
médias il le fait savoir auprès de
taille il a sa propre notoriété et quand
quelqu'un est célèbre mais il dit
quelque chose qu'on soit d'accord ou pas
les journalistes viennent
nicolas bailly sur la forme en tout cas
puisqu'on sait qu'il faut un certain
nombre de validation des maires pour
qu'un candidat soit le système ne peut
pas avoir émergé ce type de personne si
vous pensez que ce serait le cas vous
savez il ya quand même des candidatures
que certains qualifient de farfelu qui
arrivent à obtenir leurs 500 signatures
à chaque élection jacques cheminade a
réussi plusieurs fois à voir ses 500
signatures
je ne vois pas ce qui empêcherait ce
type de candidat la voir leurs 500
signatures si pour des soutiens qui se
met à faire le tour de france des mers
et pourrait obtenir 500 signatures et
ceci à ceci près que il ait eu un
changement institutionnel sous françois
hollande qui réduit la démocratie dans
notre pays qui fait que les signataires
sont maintenant public alors qu'elle
n'était pas avant ce qui rendait
beaucoup plus simple le ce jeu
démocratique avec des petits maires
qu'ils acceptaient de par esprit
démocratique de soutenir ni compris des
gens qui avec les cas n'était pas
totalement d'accord
sachant que leurs grands candidats
étaient sûrs de trouver des électeurs
maintenant que ces publics
ça devient très très compliqué parce
qu'après faut justifier devant ses
propres électeurs et souvent ça devient
un jeu des grandes chancelleries
politique qui demande à tel ou tel maire
de signer afin qu'émerge un candidat qui
nuirait à l'opposant dernière question
nicolas bailly ce le fait de côtoyer de
s'afficher avec ces personnes
est-ce que ça décrédibilise emmanuel
macron même au sein de la la majorité ça
dérangeant tout de même ça peut déranger
certaines personnes moi ça me choque pas
je pense le présent la république est en
droit d'aller voir qu'il veut et d'aller
prendre la température baigneurs
permanence on en parle là parce que
c'est bigard ou didier raoul
mais quand il aura ouvert et c'est là
qu'il a appelé aussi à eric zemmour
qu'il a appelé après son agression
oui mais comme commis là tout comme il
veut appeler les bepa 30 syndicats les
patrons de njai les chefs d'entreprise
comme s'adresse aux citoyens lambda
quand il est en déplacement le prix dans
la république est le président de tous
les français il peut leur parler à tous
merci beaucoup merci nicollin va y en
avoir un peu la pression de la rue
réseau anonyme oui oui je suis désolé on
comprend ce que vous dites mais c'est
vrai que on a quelques salons un jeu
blanc lors de la france
merci beaucoup en tout cas d'avoir
participé à ce débat merci à vous
georges kuzmanovic d'avoir été en direct
sur rt france c'est la fin du débat
politique